here's what would happen if the largest
asteroid hit Earth
let's start small the 20 meter long
Chelyabinsk meteor actually hit Earth in
2013 and caused the equivalent explosion
of 500 000 tons of TNT okay thinking
bigger now throwing it back 65 million
years the 10 kilometer chicksalube
asteroid was so strong it's probably
what caused the dinosaurs to go extinct
if Earth took a hit from the largest
body in the asteroid belt series
there would be no more Earth it's so big
it's technically a dwarf planet the
series would block out the Sun and
remove 10 kilometers of the Earth's
crust bennu is the one you'd want to
worry about this 490 meter Wide Rock has
a 1 in 1700 chance of colliding with
Earth in September of the Year 2182 so